In this section, we're going to walk you through the hands-on station for Switchboard setup and launch.
Now, before we get started in the engine actually getting our Switchboard configuration set up,
I do want to point out that the first time you launch Switchboard,
you will need to make sure that the Python dependencies do get added to every computer you are working from
in order to synchronize everything using the Switchboard listener.
Now, as we get ready to launch, there is something that you're going to need to be aware of.
Because we're working from a stage instead of at home, you will need to enable the Perforce option in your Switchboard configuration.
This is because you're going to need version control to synchronize each of the render nodes for your Switchboard configuration.
Now, Perforce is the ideal version for control, but not a dependency if you're using other version control types or a non-network setup.
Now, let's switch over to the engine so that we can set up our Switchboard configuration.
Alright, we'll begin here by going up to our toolbar and you'll notice that I've got an option here for Launch Switchboard.
I've also got some actions related to Switchboard here, including Launch Switchboard listener and Launch Switchboard listener on login.
Now, I am going to need a listener, but one of the things I want to point out is that I already have a Switchboard listener
and Switchboard shortcut on my desktop.
You want to make sure that when you build these, you have them available and easy to work from.
Now, back into the engine, I'm going to go ahead and launch Switchboard and you'll see my Switchboard user interface pop up.
Now, I'm also going to jump back to the engine and make sure that my Switchboard listener is also launched.
Now, that pops up briefly, but I just want to point out that it looks just like this.
Now, back into Switchboard, I do want to create a new configuration as I already have one available,
but I do want to walk you through each of these steps.
So, go under configurations, which is in the upper left-hand corner of your Switchboard user interface,
and go ahead and hit new configuration.
Now, this is going to work with the path for the project that we've got in here,
and as my Perforce is already checked on and I'm already connected to Perforce, my version control is going to come up that way.
So, this will auto-populate, but you want to make sure that the Perforce path is correct.
So, go ahead and look through here and make sure that your path matches the correct location for your Perforce project.
Also, make sure that the name of the project you're working through is the same as the project that you're actually connecting to.
You'll note here that mine is not correct.
So, I'm going to go ahead and hit detect.
Hitting detect actually hit the correct configuration.
Now, once that is correct, I make sure that my workspace name is correct and hit OK.
Now, I need to actually create my configuration as well.
So, in order to do that, I want to start out with add device.
The first device I'm going to add is the Unreal Engine.
This is my control node.
So, I'm going to type in CTRL node 00 so I know that that's what I'm working from.
Now, I also need to set my IP address for this node, which in this instance is 10.14.101.69.
And I'm going to go ahead and hit OK.
That's going to load in my control node, and if I make a mistake, I can go in and make the adjustments manually here.
Now, I also want to make sure that I'm connecting to my default map.
So, I want to make sure that I'm connecting to my 118 Beach.
Now, I do want to add in another device.
That device is going to be my end display configuration.
Now, as this pops up, you'll see that I've got a pull-down menu that I can't really access right now.
Now, I can browse to it, but in order to get to it quickly, I just hit populate, and that will automatically fill in that location.
And you can see from there, I have a couple of pull-down options.
Now, just to make sure that I'm in the correct location,
I want to hit browse.
That's going to take me to the location, and I want to make sure that I'm in the correct project.
So, again, 118C.
You can see that that matches, and with that connection, I can go ahead and select my NDC asset and hit open.
So, that will give me the correct pathing again.
Once that's done, go ahead and hit OK.
This will auto-populate your multipurpose and render node, or any nodes that you have connected,
along with the correct IP addresses that are in here.
This is pulling these nodes directly from the nDisplay configuration that you've set up previously in the other section.
Now, before I connect here, I do need to make some changes.
You'll notice my multi-user session is not actually correct in here, and I have some settings that I need to cover.
So, I'm going to move up into the top of my switchboard and move my settings, settings option.
Now, I want to make some changes to my multi-user server.
So, I start here, and my server name, you can see, is Stage 11801-503-MUServer.
That's quite a mouthful, and it's a long string of text.
I want to make this a little bit shorter, and if you look at the example in the bottom left-hand corner here,
I want to follow that guideline, but you can set yours to your own naming conventions.
So, I'm going to start with MUS for multi-user session, and I'm going to take out Stage and leave in my 503C.
Then I'm going to replace MUServer here with 118c to match the project name that we're actually using here,
which you can see in this stage path.
Now, I can leave this blank, and I can make that change to my multi-user session,
but I also want to copy this so I can make sure that that exactly matches what I've got here in this session at the bottom.
Next, I want to move down to my end display configuration settings and make sure that my path is correct,
so that I'm going to this 11801c, and then my end display configuration is set.
Next, I want to go to my render node, and you'll note here that my workspace name for my render node says control.
Now, that's incorrect, because my render node has to be on a render machine.
So, that workspace name is going to be changed to RNDR to match the render workspace that we're actually being worked from.
Now, I don't need to make other changes unless I have a completely different path,
but the project for the U project should match stage 11801503CU project,
and you can just see that that actually matches there.
Next, I want to move to the multi-P server and make sure that that workspace name also matches the multi-P.
So, I want to change that to MLTP and make sure that this changes.
Now, you'll note that these both change to gold.
That's just an indicator that there is a change to this auto-populated system for that workspace name,
and it's a good indicator to let you know that your pathing is correct.
Next, I want to move down to my control node and make sure that my workspace name for control matches the workspace for this particular machine.
So, noting that these are correct, I want to go ahead and hit X here to close this window,
and that should save my configuration.
So, again, just hit X, and now I want to make some changes here to this server name.
So, I'm going to paste in the information for my multi-user session,
and I'm going to go ahead and underscore this and start to iterate here.
I'm going to give this the date, so this is 120722 for today's date,
and I'm going to iterate 01 as this is the first time I'm going to join that session.
I'm going to go ahead and hit enter, but before I actually make that connection,
I'm going to go back into my settings and verify that those changes I made actually changed.
Easiest way to do that is to see if these are still gold, and if they are gold, you are golden.
Okay, so we verified our settings for our control nodes, and now we're ready to connect our devices.
First, I'm going to hit this button here, and that will connect all of our Unreal devices,
and next, you'll see that this turns active, so I can actually connect with all of these,
but I just need to connect my nodes for my end display.
Once that's connected, you'll note that I got an error here that says that my render node cannot retrieve my change list.
That's okay, because I've got a sync button here where I can now sync all devices,
so I'm going to go ahead and click that.
Now that I've synchronized all my devices, there's one more thing I need to do.
I need to make sure that I select my map, so I'm going to go from my default map to my beach map.
That's going to make sure that I'm actually launching in the correct project map for my level inside Unreal Engine.
Now, I'm ready to launch, but I don't need this instance, because Switchboard is going to launch a new instance of Unreal Engine.
So from here, I'm just going to switch back to Unreal Engine and go ahead and close this.
Now that that's closed, I've got myself 100% ready to launch the engine here.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit this button here, which is to start all connected devices.
Now, if you're working on a private build, you will also need to build the engine in addition to actually synchronizing everything.
There are some other options in here, so you can build all devices or build and synchronize with your change list immediately after your build is completed.
Okay, so let's go ahead and start all my connected devices.
Now, you'll see this launches my multi-user server.
You'll also see that this is going to launch an instance of Unreal Engine.
As Unreal Engine launches, we'll be able to see what happens on the wall as the engine actually connects.
So let's look at the wall.
Now, you'll see that the wall has gone black.
As the wall goes black, it connects everything to it.
But once it's done, you'll see the engine load and populate and the wall change, and then the inner frustrum pop to fit your camera view.
Now, once that's up and running, you'll see that all of your devices are connected.
And if you switch back to Unreal Engine, you can see that the engine itself has launched the version of the control here.
Now, you'll also see that our multi-user session connects so that you can see my control node, my multi-purpose node, and my render node are connected to my multi-user session.
If I want to make any kind of adjustments, I do want to move down to this bottom right-hand corner and make sure that I've connected to source control.
Once I've connected to source control, you'll notice that the provider says multi-user and not Perforce.
Even though I select Perforce, it's going to retain that multi-user provider because it's connected to all of my devices.
Once that's done, I want to choose my available workspace and accept my settings.
Once connected, you should get a connection successful option.
Now, as you work through your Perforce, you are going to want to make sure that you persist any session changes.
And then once those changes are correct, then you submit your content.
Now, let's jump back to our slides and review what we did for our previous launch.
Now, as we were getting ready to launch, the first thing that we did is make sure that our switchboard listener is connected.
And then from here, we launched both our switchboard listener and our switchboard session.
Again, you do have the option of keeping a few shortcuts on your desktop, which we highly recommend for your production,
so that you can quickly launch your listener and your switchboard instance from those shortcuts.
Now, as you move into your switchboard, you do want to make sure again that your level is correct
and that you then connect your devices first and then change your multi-user session to iterate whatever your session is.
Now, you may only do one multi-user session for a production in the morning and then again in the afternoon.
You might run one session for the entire day, or you might iterate every time you take the wall down and go back up.
It's really up to what you want to use as your user and preference for your production.
Once you're ready to go, again you hit this launch button that you can see in your slides,
and then that will connect all of those devices.
In order to take this down, that send icon will change to a stop X icon after launch.
Now that you're ready to go, you have already connected to switchboard through the wall and transacted to the LED volume.